the American Dream means equal
opportunities to achieve your dream
well twin brothers who work the grape
fields of central California and dreamed
of making a difference are now
celebrating their graduations from
medical school they shared their story
with Jonathan Vigliotti dr. oka vo
Vieira Montes there's no one path to
graduation and no to you know that
better than Octavio dr. omar vo Montes
and Omar Vieira Montes the twins
graduated from Harvard and UCLA med
school respectively just one day apart
Octavio and Omar's family moved from
Mexico to Central California when they
were 10 to chase the American dream
which for newly arrived immigrants meant
picking grapes in the fields and selling
produce door-to-door the first year it
was tough we hated it but we start to
realize that we were doing this for a
specific reason and it was to help our
family to help each other and their
parents helped them their mother
introducing them to the town library
showing them how education was the most
valuable currency that was the safe
haven for both of you every single time
I entered that library it will say I was
entering a different world even by
reading a different book you know he
gave me imagination to be somewhere else
somewhere else but also grounded in
their studies the twins
aced their classes graduating high
school and sharing the coveted title of
valedictorian Octavio went to Harvard
undergrad Omar off to UC San Diego both
on full scholarships then graduate
school and the decision to become
doctors what was that moment like when
you received your letter from Harvard
you've received your letter from UCLA
saying congratulations you've been
accepted into med school when I saw that
UCLA had offered me admission a
full-ride scholarship I was very
ecstatic why would they pick someone
from a small town of 5,000 people to go
to Harvard Medical School I remember
refreshing the page I guess making sure
that you know it was addressed to the
right person and to me do you reflect on
the sacrifices they've made so that you
can live this life
that you're living now I think that
seriously and that's why every day I
wake up and and I think how can i what
can I do today to make myself better my
family better in my community the power
of a dream planted at a young age for
CBS this morning Saturday Jonathan
Vigliotti Los Angeles that's really
great to see isn't it I love the line
education being the most valuable
currency yeah so true and the idea that
a book can open up your mind yeah and
they do it together that that really
makes that makes the mark proud mom and
dad congratulations to all of them